marioupol ville assiégée par l'armée
russe annonce vouloir évacuer ces civils
à partir de 10h gmt des couloirs
humanitaires devaient être mises en
place après un accord pour un cessez le
feu qui s'était soldée par un échec
cette ville au sud est de l'ukraine
située sur la mer d'azov est en ce
moment au centre des préoccupations sa
conquête permettrait de relier les zones
séparatistes du donbass à la crim est
annexée par la russie il ya huit ans des
dizaines de véhicules des deux blindés
russes sa masse dans la ville depuis
plusieurs jours les 450 mille habitants
de la ville vivent sans eau ni
électricité ni essence et dans la peur
des bombardements fuir peut également
s'avérer risqué ici un convoi de
journalistes tentent de quitter la zone
et se retrouve encerclé par des soldats
qui se met en position de tir
ce temps qui dirige son canon en
direction des voitures pour permettre
aux civils de quitter la ville un cessez
le feu avait été décrété mais russe des
ukrainiens s'accusent mutuellement de ne
pas l'avoir respecté
les russes nous ont dit que la route de
marioupol à zaporijia est sûr mais nous
avons reçu des informations selon
lesquelles il ya de violents combats sur
cette route 1 ensuite ils continuent à
bombarder marioupol donc nous avons
demandé aux habitants de ne pas rester à
attendre dans la rue
une accusation démentie samedi par la
russie daniel ce qui prouve que nous
avons été informés que les autorités de
marioupol refuse de donner aux habitants
la possibilité de partir par le couloir
humanitaire où es tu pour une mise en
place par l'armée russe précise qu'une
voyeur de son côté le chef de l'état
ukrainien wladimir zelensky ne décolère
pas contre l'otan et son refus d'imposer
une zone d'exclusion mer dans le ciel un
créneau par cette décision l'otan veut
éviter une confrontation directe avec la
russie ni paul dans une déclaration
publique vladimir poutine a mis en garde
les occidentaux qui compte qu imposerait
une zone d'exclusion aérienne au-dessus
du grain serait considérée comme sco
belligérants